the infiltration case ends and then my
true
identity like who they thought to be
Jaybird Davis turns out to be Jay
Dobbins the gun Runner debt collector
turns out to be an ATF agent so that the
Angels issued contracts on me they were
farmed out to the Aryan Brotherhood they
were farmed out to the MS-13 18th Street
picked one up here in Los Angeles
[Music]
come on
I want to start just by saying how how
much of an honor this is for me man like
uh we're full disclosure we're meeting
for real the first time today
um it's a it's a joy for me and um I'm
so grateful that you would do this uh I
read your book uh years ago years ago
and um I was uh utterly blown away and
and fascinated
um in my opinion um you're nothing short
of a hero you exemplify courage strength
um your wild man uh I I I learned so
much strangely about my whole acting
process uh by the way that uh you
approached your work um I do it uh you
know my work is putting on makeup and
saying lines for a living and I operate
under the umbrella of safety uh you put
yourself out there in um uh such an
insane way in your life um and I just I
have so much respect for you and I'm so
glad that I get the chance to actually
kind of meet you and look you in the eye
so so thank you man thank you thank you
for coming bro so when you compare like
uh like acting to you know and like your
process yeah so I've been uh I've like
I've been in a couple films right
acting playing uh a cop yep right
is much harder to do as an actor than it
is to do operationally on the street why
is that
when you're when you're acting you you
have a script to follow you have a
director there who's who's orchestrating
things you're surrounded by a crew
and it it steals all your spontaneity
like if I'm if I'm out on the street I
can take it and I can control the
situation however I want by what I say
by what I do
um by my actions I don't you don't have
the freedom for that as an actor right
so like when I've had some acting spots
like small right nothing uh to uh be uh
of significance I thought it was super
hard like you have to deliver a line and
you have to like honor the writer's
words sure and the directors
instructions and all the people looking
I thought it was way harder but I
imagine with so many of the the so many
of the undercover agents that you've
worked with over the years I'm sure you
I mean there's something that set you
apart correct like your ability to
improvise your ability to go deeper your
ability I mean I'm we're just talking
about Mel Chancey and I I want to get
into like a proper introduction all that
but we're just talking about Mel Chancey
and I one of the things that really
struck me is is uh you know when you
were in New York you were there I think
at like a convention or you were there
with like a bunch of other ATF agents
and you were like I want to go over to
the Hell's Angels Clubhouse like I want
to just go over there because you're so
sort of deeply you know in this guy and
in this guy's soul and in this guy's
shoes and you know the other agents were
like you out of your [__] mind but
you made your connections you called
your people in Arizona they got you in
and that's where you met yeah Mel who's
a a friend of both of ours
um you know sort of legendary Hell's
Angel but
you know you wanting to do that you you
you having both the urge to do that
knowing that it might help your case or
it might just be that's where you want
it to be maybe you felt more comfortable
with those guys than you did with the
agents at that time you I I doubt that
that's a common thing for undercover
operatives I I think what is common is
there's all these different elements and
personalities the one common factor
amongst all the guys that are great is
they're audacious
that there's there's some that have
various levels of risk assessment
various levels of Courage uh various
looks various experiences understanding
of the tradecraft all those things but
every one of the great ones is just
audacious yeah
they just have they just have the balls
to um you know uh
not be afraid to fail be afraid to not
try is worse than failing it's like
Jordan says man you miss a hundred
percent of the shots you don't take
that's right so
so take your shot and and if and if risk
if if if uh risk beca is is a factor in
it
you know then you're probably not going
to be very good at it because everything
you do is a risk everything you do is
risky there's no guarantees right right
and would you just like quickly I just I
mean just uh you know with who I I just
want people to have an idea kind of who
you are like you're going to see very
quickly
um this this is not my [__] day job
you know this is not going to be uh this
is definitely not uh Walter Cronkite
it's definitely not [__] David
Letterman but I wanted to you know you
with all that I'll dumb it down from
there I appreciate it bro I I think you
know for me I just think it's really
important that people know uh look you
know kind of who you are and where
you're from because to me I feel like
you know like the books that you've
written and um what you've done law
enforcement in this in this country and
sort of your struggles within law
enforcement with the very Bureau that
you gave so much to I feel like there's
also so much more to you that I I don't
know and I'm I'm fascinated to find out
but I mean you infiltrated the Hell's
Angels and uh brought probably the
biggest case in the history of that
organization against them
um a two-year process uh that is really
in my opinion unlike anything that has
like ever really been done in law
enforcement before
um one thing in your book and your book
just resonated with me in so many
different ways and I've read it now
multiple times in my life you know you
start off by saying very specifically
you did not grow up you didn't get beat
up you didn't grow up struggling for
food you did not tell me a little bit
about how you grow up and tell me a
little bit about your sort of first
encounters with violence um because
you're a guy who who has encountered
violence and sort of like walked into
the face of violence uh with a level of
Courage that I don't think is uh like
sort of anybody else that we've had here
before you know when I was a kid I was
the heavyweight champion of sissies and
like I don't believe that bro it's so
you also got an NFL contract and played
four years division one football and
total [__] badass on the athletic
field but yeah so I'll tell you like I'm
I'm a kid I'm like eight years old
there's a neighborhood bully who's
beaten the dog crap out of me in my
front yard he's bigger than me stronger
than me he's got me pinned down I'm on
my back just smacking the crap out of me
and I hear the screen door open on our
house
and I'm like
my like my Dad's here my my heroes here
he's coming to the rescue right
and I hear I can't see him but I hear my
dad behind me saying keep hitting him
and I'm like wait a minute man keep
hitting him
and and the the bully like kind of like
is is confused and my dad's like keep
hitting him hit him like you hit him
before I came out and the kid starts
smacking me again and my dad's like
Jerry you're gonna fight back are you
gonna do something you're just gonna lay
there and take a beating and I'm like
Dad he's too big he's too strong right
so the guy takes a few more blows gets
up and the kid runs off he's like
freaked out like his you know someone's
father's watching him kick his son's ass
right I remember my dad came over and he
picked me up and my nose was bleeding
and he's like you have to learn to fight
back because if you don't you're gonna
be a victim for the rest of your life
there's always someone bigger and
stronger out there than you you have to
fight back no matter what
like that was like like almost as an
eight-year-old wow like I was turned wow
I was like you know and my dad's like
was my hero is my hero he's the best man
I've ever known uh the best man I ever
hoped to know um
like all these lessons in life that like
that was hard for him sure you know and
he picked me up and he ruffled my hair
and then he's like now let's go in and
get some ice on that lip you know and it
like for a dad man that's heart like
it's hard to do super hard anybody
that's that's got a kid sure like like
now putting myself in in my Dad's shoes
at that point I'm like that was really
hard for him but that was like a like a
teaching moment like hey I'm trying to
I'm trying to raise like a a good man
sure sure and do you and and did that
did that change things the next time
that that's something was it acute was
that change is something getting ignited
it changed in a in a in kind of in a bad
way in that when I uh when I did punch
back and when I did learn to fight back
got carried away I I kind of liked it
yeah I liked being on the other side of
it and that's just as dangerous of
course being uh like a bully's a bully
good guy's side or bad boy side of
course of course um and so it was a was
there anything your old man did to kind
of curb that in you like did he ever see
that side of you did he ever did he ever
ask you to pull back on that or get you
to see yourself in a different way I I
think that um
what he saw and what he enjoyed is like
when I became involved in sports sure
the recklessness that that creates
that's how you play sports especially
when you're an underachiever especially
or when you're undersized and under
speed and and under strength like how do
you make up like how do you compete
against those people that have all these
physical like gifts that you don't have
you just you're reckless describe
yourself as a receiver you know the the
way that you describe yourself in in in
in the book
um I'd like to say on a much sort of
smaller level not even closer it's
exactly I used to describe myself as a
receiver as being sort of an
underachiever not the fastest not the
strongest but that's actually a position
that I think is usually sort of goes
hand in hand with the glory or the fast
guy you're burning them deep but you
know the kind of receiver I I love crack
back blocks I loved uh shortyard
receptions yeah I love dragging people
over to get that first down I love
hitting people as that position can you
sort of describe yourself as a football
player yeah exactly that I I tried to
make up for my shortcomings by just
playing Wild playing Reckless trying to
be Fearless
I was never the guy who ran down the
sidelines and and caught the ball over
his shoulder and scored a touchdown and
got a date with the prom queen right I
was the guy who like ran the slant to
get the first down so the other cat
could catch the touchdown that's right
but I was all I was super proud of that
absolutely I knew what my role was it
was not to be the star it was not to be
uh like the glory guy my role was very
defined and very specific and I embraced
it and that's how I stayed on the field
and how do you feel like you you carry
that you know you're a star player in in
high school that took you to University
Arizona and played you know division one
college football you know got got looks
from the NFL I mean how did how did the
mentality of football I know you're
you're coaching today how did like how
did football sort of shape you for your
career and how did it what lessons did
you learn from it yeah it's just it's
such a I don't think there's any sport
that teaches you life's lessons as well
as football and all the things that come
within and not just the sport not just
the tactics and the techniques of it but
the teamwork of it and and the
coordination that it takes and like
knowing your role and and understanding
your hierarchy
um in the process that that's and that's
life yep that's you know football like
like acting or producing a film like
uh an undercover operation
maintaining a just a relationship a
personal relationship running a family a
small business a big business
we all have the same
process this and look maybe we don't
even really if you haven't thought about
it we don't really understand it
to be like the people that are truly
successful in life the highest Achievers
are the best problem solvers that's
right so whatever is in front of you
identify whatever that objective is
what's the mission what's the goal then
the next step is communication with the
people around you open transparent
communication worry exchanging ideas
when you do that you build trust because
you because now you're part of a team
and then with all those things in line
now you can go solve whatever problem X
is whether it's in your relationship
whether it's boy girl stuff whether it's
managing kids or a wife or a husband
making a movie running undercover
operation small business big businesses
like our process is the same and like if
you don't think about it like all of us
spend our entire day solving problems
that's right that's right and the people
that are are super high Achievers are
really good at it and and I and you know
you're talking you
the way that you're sort of uh able to
put that now is coming from a place of
just being an enormously High achiever
yourself and looking back on this sort
of unparalleled career but I I'm really
interested in the guy like before you
went into the ATF before you decided to
become an undercover operative you know
there's a level like you use the word
recklessness right like I I like to
think of that um it's what attracts me
again in a much different sort of way to
the acting look man again there's no
words for the life that you you've lived
and I guess I'm really interested you
know in this guy who decides to to to to
make a life of uh being an undercover
operative in the most dangerous of
situations where were you sort of like
with violence and recklessness at that
point in your life well you know I'll
tell you uh the honest truth is I'm very
much a common man who's been placed in
uncommon situations and then just done
the best I could in that situation
um found some success at times and
failed Stakes a lot of times too yeah
um you know if and if we don't talk
about the mistakes and if we don't talk
about the failures then then there's
then what I say doesn't have credibility
agreed if all we do is like tell Hero
Stories and Pat myself on the back
totally um and try to uh like build upon
some uh myth then it's all counterfeit
but but what makes it I mean what what
were you hungry for you know this
decision to go into the ATF and go into
this world and wanting to be into like
what was it about that that was you know
drawing you in the uh the Intrigue of it
the challenge uh like the kind of the
one-on-one challenge the competition of
it undercover work you're in competition
it's a competition of you versus either
uh the the suspect you're working on the
group you're working on yeah you're
competing with them and they're
competing against you yeah
um the criminal Community is uniquely
paranoid and they have to be because
that's how they stay stay out of prison
they don't trust you they don't like
strangers
and so there's a competition there
you're TR like I'm trying to sell myself
sure it's it's it's Jordan Belfort it's
it's Wolf of Wall Street sell me this
pen sure well I'm the pen yeah like I'm
selling you yep like
trust me believe you don't know me you
don't have any experience with me you
didn't grow up with me sell me your
drugs sell me your guns sell me your
bombs involve me in your home invasion
scheme hire me to do the murder you want
done selling me yep yep and building
that credibility it's all about building
that is basically your coat of armor
right like that is how you do that and
is admitting your failures is that part
of building your credibility is is being
exactly who you are I I mean I really
want to talk about you know how you work
with Ci's and how you how you sort of
like build this this this this role but
um you know look man I mean you're one
of your first outings out there you you
you got shot right and and uh can you
take us through that story and I know
you don't want to just tell Hero Stories
but that I'm it's a crazy [__] story
so and I'm going to tie this to uh
to your to your HBO show right now
there's a there's a tie in here right
please uh until we own the city love it
um I got hired on a Monday 1987. I I I
was a failed athlete I'd like I I had
always planned on playing in the NFL yep
um and then I I never had a plan B I
never planned for anything other than
that because that's what I was going to
do well you know it turns out like dude
you ain't good enough to play in the NFL
right so you like so now you're left
like a lot of young people now what
right so
at the time this is mid 80s Miami Vice
was popular and as an audience we had
never seen a cop show like that right we
had seen all the procedurals detectives
responding reactively to crime scenes
doing interviews patrolmen right and
then all of a sudden Sonny Crockett
shows up on the scene got the Hugo Boss
on he's riding a Lambo around South
Beach
right and he's he's going into these
mansions and he's meeting with these
glamorous kingpins and there's a ton of
cocaine out on some barge in the harbor
and he's got these like stripper models
bringing them Mojitos right and I'm like
man I like that seems pretty cool yeah
yeah right so
the reality of it is
what I found the reality is that
that Lamborghini it was like a Beatdown
Monte Carlo sure right and the Hugo Boss
suit was like cut off camos and a wife
beater t-shirt and flip-flops right the
the Kingpin that's that Sonny Crockett
was dealing with was some like broke
dick dude who didn't have two nickels to
rub together that was sitting at the end
of the bar with his plumber's crack
hanging out here right the ton of
cocaine it was an eight ball that was so
stepped on with baby likes it if you'd
[__] before you'd get high off of it
right and then the the the stripper
models that like you see on TV that are
like running with these cats
they're like straight skanks with like
three teeth in their head and tits like
sweat socks with rocks in the toes and
so when I when I experienced it and it
was so much different than what
Hollywood had sold me on sure sure I
[__] loved it every day man every day
I loved it it wasn't glamorous
undercover work is a nasty dirty bloody
vomit-covered scab of a life and when I
realized that I still loved it yeah yeah
and what was it that you loved I love
the challenge of the competition of it I
loved how dirty it was I didn't have to
be the guy with the gold chains and the
Rolex and all the and all the you know
driving the the Ferrari like I I didn't
care I'd show up like on a bicycle for
deals ride ride a bike because that's
that's how some of those cats roll how
early in their career was that that that
that first event where you got wounded
that well so like I get hired on a
Monday yeah right so I actually was out
here in Los Angeles got sworn in and I
told my supervisors I want to work
undercover I came to work undercover
sure so
supervisor digs in his desk and he hands
me a cassette tape and some headphones
and all it said on it was Marty right so
I plug it in and I'm listening what it
was was
the audio recording of a Baltimore City
Baltimore Police Department narcotics
officer named Marcellus Ward Marty Ward
holy [__] who Marty in December of 1984
was in an undercover deal with a heroin
dealer and was shot like five or six
times point blank in a drug dealer's
apartment and Marty in Baltimore in
Baltimore and Marty dies on tape Marty
like Marty dies with his boys trying to
rescue him until you hear him die right
so so guys shot him left and then you
hear his backup unit come in trying to
save him yeah and it is
dude I'll send you the recording it's
it
it's it's it's hard yeah it's hard to
listen to right so
I come out I'm listening to tape my my
boss is like hey man you still want to
work undercover I'm like yeah man this
dude's a freaking hero like I'm not I'm
not gonna die doing it but right so four
days later I get I get hired
I want to work undercover they make me
listen to the Marty tape they're trying
to like hey dude you need to know what
you're getting into right
four days later I get taken hostage and
shot
um
the bullet went in my back it went in uh
between my uh can you just how did you
get how did you get taken hostage so
actually it's there's there's so many
stories and backstories to everything
right I know I know so so like I'm brand
new and like I've I haven't been to the
academy I don't have any training
um I I wasn't a street guy right
so I'm like on the the outer tertiary
like most distant perimeter of this
arrest operation sure the suspect shows
up
he shows up on a motorcycle gets off his
motorcycle parks in front of his house
starts walking in all the units all the
all the surveillance units start
swooping in on them
to um to make the arrest sure well he he
takes off he takes off running
and so I'm like I'm in so far in the
distance like I'm supposed to just be
staying out of the out of the work right
I see the cat running while I start
running right so like I was I wasn't
fast enough to play in the NFL I was
slow but I was freaking yeah yeah I was
uh Usain Bolt in Copland right
so I start like I'm passing dudes and
chasing we're running through the
neighborhood and he's Serpentine and
zigzagging yeah and I and I lose the
dude he vanishes he knows where he's at
I don't know where he's at yeah
um
short time later like we're we're just
kind of searching creeping for the dude
are you still do you still have your
guys around you or they're like we're
all spreading okay right so everybody's
like you know there's like no one's
really nearby or close
um and the dude was hiding man and he
popped up and and Drew down on me and I
like I had my gun and he was like
[__] I will [__] kill you
where you stand right and I'm like
you know I don't remember seeing this uh
episode of my advice right right
the Dude Gets behind me puts the gun to
my head and and he puts his gun to your
head right and he says I'll kill you
where you're saying has anybody ever
said that to you in your life that had
anybody drawn a gun on you before in
your life no so now there's a gun at
your head what do you feel what are you
feeling man well like I didn't have uh
like those types of life experiences to
refer back to like okay what do I do now
right but there but there is a sports
element to it there is a like a football
element to it things are breaking bad
there's chaos there's Panic man you're
losing the game
you don't help yourself by becoming
hysterical right you find your you find
your Zen you find a sense of calm and
you try to like let your computer run
you know I mean have you ever seen
anyone else with that little experience
go to that place
I mean I I mean I imagine it's like you
were specifically
wired that way both you know for
football you know the blood that your
your mom and dad put in you you know I
mean not most people most people get a
gun to their head like that
and I mean they're pissing their pants
right they're not getting tactical you
got you took a breath and got tactical
and again it's not hero worship nothing
like that I'm just wondering what is
going through your your head I mean a
gun was once put up put you know put to
my head once in in Russia and and I knew
into I felt like I was this but like I I
immediately turned into a book I was
literally like you I I'm here for you
I'll do whatever you want I'm just
wondering what went through your because
I I look I know this story I want you to
tell the rest of the story but like how
do you go tactical at that point
um
because I mean you didn't have a ton of
training right no I had no training but
I think it's uh it's it's an inherent
survival Instinct like like panic's
gonna get me nowhere panic's gonna get
me shot yeah like right now yep
um
in in any kind of situation like those
life and death situations if you're
talking if you're communicating you're
alive you're still in the game yeah just
keep moving right keep like keep
thinking keep planning okay so what
happens next so the dude uh
has got the gun to my head and uh I
talked about this old like like I
thought I was coming out of the job to
this Lamborghini right like this old
Monte Carlo right that we used to show
up there he stuffs me in the front seat
of Monte Carlo he gets behind me and
he's got the gun to my head
um and he's like saying like go like get
me out of here right like like he like
he wanted to use me as his vehicle to
escape the situation well now the other
agents are starting to close in right
so I'm thinking like you know what man
this this probably has got a bad ending
but like I'm not gonna drive this dude
away from here with all these other
agents all these other armed agents I'm
not going to drive this dude away from
here and and have him kick me out and
execute me in the ditch 20 miles down
the road you knew that that was what was
going right I was like if this is going
down it ain't it's going down and were
you playing the the Audio I mean in your
head I mean did you go back to the to
the Baltimore undercover agent yeah yeah
absolutely right I'd only heard that
tape a couple days before right so it
was like that that story was Super Fresh
in my mind and and and Marty's demise
and and oh right so
sitting there and I'm sitting behind the
wheel and I see a telephone pole like 30
yards up in front the first thing I
thought is like I'm going to buckle my
seat belt and I'm going to run us into
that telephone pole as hard as I can get
this car going as fast as I can get it
going and that's that's gonna at least
give me a chance right so I'm going to
buckle my seat belt and the keys are in
the ignition of the of the car
and I'm like okay plan B man I pulled
the keys out and I dropped them to the
floorboard and he's screaming at me like
let's go let's go let's you know he's
he's he's he's uh he's messed up sir
um
and I reach forward to grab the keys and
when I he tried to ride forward with me
and the gun came off my head the gun
actually moved to my back he's trying to
stay with me and ride me right and he's
holding the gun on my back and then
everything breaks bad he fires around
um hits me in the back goes through my
lung narrowly misses my heart exits my
chest
and then that inspires like literally
uh this lead and glass storm like that
that you could only imagine in a movie
right right it was like it was five or
ten seconds I think like
20 or 25 rounds were fired into the car
right into the into the compartment we
were in
um so I brought this because I because I
knew that story would come up right [__]
so that hole right there that's where
the bullet went in my back come on right
and this hole right here
that hole right there is where it came
out of my came out of my chest wow right
so like I said got hired on a Monday
like this goes down four days later on a
Thursday with the feds
John we get paid every two weeks I
didn't even gotten a paycheck yet huh I
didn't get if I comp him this one this
was on the house man this was like a
test drive like Hey man can I try can I
come back tomorrow
right
and there was like I mean I'm laying in
the dirt and dog crap of this trailer
park and there's blood coming out of my
chest like you're holding your thumb
over the end of a garden hose
just squirting out and then they dragged
the suspect out of the back of the car
because he I mean they ventilated this
dude
um his eyes are rolled back he's already
got the death rattle going and um
so they pushed me now into the back seat
of this car
and I'm like and I'm I'm in bad shape
myself yeah and so the same card that
the shooting took place in we take off
for the hospital
and so like and my boss was driving who
was like a good experienced like old
school cop and he's driving and hauling
ass and he's looking over his shoulder
into the back seat like hang on hang
he's called everybody Bubba hang on
bubba hang on bubba stay with me Bubba
and then he's driving and driving and
driving and he's like man do you know
your way do you know the way to the
hospital because we're down here
and I'm like free I got blood gushing
out of my chest and like glasses all in
me right and I'm like like my ears are
bleeding and I [__]
so but you know what
um it has a really it has a really happy
ending it has a good ending actually the
the trauma surgeon that that operated on
me is a guy named Dr Richard Carmona
okay um and he was this young like super
hot shot trauma surgeon right so he
patches me up he saves my life
Dr Carmona ultimately becomes the
Surgeon General of the United States
under President Bush well
um and is just is a is a a remarkable
amazing man amazing life's experiences
wow um so
like like what's the chance that this
Hall goes down and then I land in the
hands
trauma surgeon on the planet yeah right
there's like more to do there's always a
silver lining yeah yeah yeah and then
and then the decision I mean just
because I I I gotta ask was there any
doubt I mean was there was there any
like I don't know if this is for me like
what like I mean you you jump right back
in correct well so I'm in the hospital
and I'm and I'm recovering
and like the uh the ambulance Chaser
attorneys are lining up like it's like
uh like trying to return something at
Home Depot like hey take a number man
I'm now serving number 17. right they
were all taking their turn and they were
coming in saying dude you haven't been
trained that the government the agency
has assumed a huge amount of liability
for allowing this to happen to you how
much money do you want
and I'm like like I mean I grew up in a
blue collar house man my dad was a
carpenter right and my mom was a house
cleaner right
um they're like you ever seen five
million dollars wow and I'm like
no yeah how about 10 million dollars you
know what that looks like I can get you
money that's generational money like
you'll never have to work another day in
your life neither will your kids or
their kids
right right
um
like like your family will be taken care
of forever and all I could think of was
like like get out like there's no
there's no cop who ever took a badge in
a gun thinking that they were going to
get rich right thinking that they were
gonna you take it for other reasons
right right and and so the money the
money set like now at 60 I'm thinking
like man you know what 35 years ago man
I could have done a lot of money with a
lot with that money over 35 years right
but at the time I was like man get like
all I wanted to do was get back to work
I I understand the honor in that and I I
understand but but what was driving you
like if you could if you could Whittle
it down to one thing like what was what
was the desire to get back to work what
was the desire because I mean you still
need to learn this trade yeah and you
basically have suffered at this point
pretty much the worst I mean I would
imagine losing a partner or losing
somebody would be right but but I mean
you know you you kind of face the
ultimate what was it that was driving
you to get into that I mean was it this
this oath that you took was it you
really want to catch bad guys I mean you
talked about Miami but like what was it
failure yeah I'd failed did you look at
that day as a failure yep you did how so
um the fact that I was brand new
um that like by my own mistakes by my
own errors in judgment by my own
inability to assess risk I had I had
created the situation no one asked me to
come off the perimeter and chase this
cat down right so I felt like I was
embarrassed wow I was um Beyond
embarrassed I was humiliated wow like I
was the um I was the joke at the water
cooler hey man did you hear about this
dude in Tucson he was on the job four
days and he almost got smoked freaking
had a through and through like it was
humiliating how how common is it for uh
an undercover agent or or or you know
whatever it was that you were doing at
that point I mean I think there's like a
real misconception about sort of the
dangers that are out I mean how common
is it for for an officer like that to
get shot
um
well in today's world versus like 1987
it was very uncommon in today's world
every day we're reading about some cop
getting shot and and not like on its on
a drug deal we're talking about dudes
getting sniped getting ambushed right
getting uh getting squared off on
traffic standing it's almost like the
patrolmen are it's like the most
dangerous job now yeah it's it's yeah
it's never been harder to be a cop than
it is right now so when you go back in
then is there a new commitment to
training I mean is that sort of like is
that what the next stage of your life is
is it just like train your ass off
I knew I could do it but um like so like
my my previous plan a was to play
professional football play in the NFL
right fail didn't make it didn't achieve
it go to plan B right off the bat fail
I'm like man like I gotta break this
cycle 99.9 of people would say Hey [__]
man I I played four years you know
University of Arizona I got you know NFL
looks like that that doesn't sound like
a failure to me but but but but what
about you made it look that way just
because your mindset was I'm going all
the way with this yeah and I think that
like just my personality is I'm I'm
self-critical
um I do you think you need to be
self-critical in order to be successful
I I personally do yeah me too um I I am
very rarely pleased or satisfied with
anything I accomplished and I always
find the mistake or the flaw or the
error
um
is that good or bad man I don't know
I'll tell you what like I think we both
know people that uh uh achieve on a
marginal level and they'll tell you how
amazing they are and how fabulous they
are and they'll Pat themselves on the
back
um and some of them actually seem pretty
happy sometimes I'm like well [__] man
maybe I ought to just do that man
they're [__] enjoying the weekends
while I'm working you know what I mean
they're with their kids and [__]
living life you know yeah I I get it I
get it and so so you know I just want to
go I I mean I know then you know the
next 20 years of your life are dedicated
to this
you don't just sort of unparalleled un
uh undercover career and obviously you
know most of the notoriety it goes to
what you did with the Hell's Angels
but I mean there were so many criminals
that and so many criminal you know
Enterprises that you infiltrated and I
guess I'm wondering like you know we
talked a little bit about like building
credibility and I really I'm really
really interested in that like how you
do that and how you did that and so
basically
because I know when you kind of came
onto the Angels task you you know you
weren't really a motorcycle gang guy
right like you were basically you had
this role right you were like a hit man
like like what was I was not the right
choice
when the uh when the opportunity came to
work the Hell's Angels case the case
agent approached me and said hey I want
you to lead this undercover operation
and my first response was I can name 10
guys off the top of my head who will
serve this role for you better than I
will
um they were guys who that was what they
focused on that's what their expertise
was they were um they they had built
themselves and and their experience
towards that I hadn't meaning they had
spent the bulk of their career sort of
in The Outlaw Biker communities they
already had connections in those
communities exactly what were what was
your where were you at at that point
like what was your guy I was like and I
recycled this cover story over and over
I was just this white trash Peckerwood
debt collector gun Runner uh quasi-hit
man at times
um and like I could recycle that over
and over and over again I could play
that and make it I could sell it I don't
care if you're a white collar guy on
Wall Street or if you were uh pushing
everything you own in a shopping cart
like I could find a way to make that fit
and sell it to what you needed in the
criminal world and how do you sell it
like
um like well first of all like and and
and you know this from like probably
from your early days when you had to
audition for films right when you had to
go read when you're trying to get
started you get one chance at a first
impression that's it and you better hit
it um now if you don't make a good first
impression are you dead in the water
probably not but now you've put yourself
behind the eight ball man now you got to
recover just get back to even right can
you think of a time where you feel like
you didn't make a good first impression
oh
um when I didn't make a good first
impression probably with my wife
right put myself behind the eight ball
and had to make it come back you know
it's all of our stories out there if
you've got your eyes set on something
you will keep going straight up bro
straight up but but I I guess what I'm
wondering is like this this character
Jaybird David like is that who he was
like was he a specific guy like how well
did you know this guy that you were
playing there's in my experience there's
three types of like undercover uh
operators that like are the high-end
guys I'm not talking about like drive
through the park and put your hand out
and some kid's gonna drop a crack rock
and like like like to anybody right
right
there's a
there's the actors who like put on a
costume whatever that role is and they
inherit that Persona and they're acting
through it then there's but that's
mostly used for like sort of street
level I'm doing this today to achieve
this today not building a Persona in
order if I meet this guy he tells this
guy then you get to meet that guy you're
finally going to get to your target
right which is a much different level
yeah
so there's there's people that just like
they almost put on a costume and inherit
that they they start acting in that role
then there's like the Hustler who we all
know who's just like like a used car
salesman you sell anybody anything man
he's the guy that can sell ice to
Eskimos on and he's just and he's always
on the hustle yeah right and then
there's like somewhere in between there
is just the naturals and I like I I
consider myself in that what you see is
what you get
um I didn't I didn't pretend to be
something I wasn't
um I I didn't communicate with people I
was working on or against any different
than I'm talking to you sure like and
and you might like me or you might not
like me but like but I'm not acting and
I'm not pretending to be uh something
I'm not this is just who I am
so
the the key in undercover work is like
what value can you bring to whoever it
is that you're targeting if if like for
the Hell's Angels there's a million
dudes who have Harleys that are sitting
at the bar at the at the end of the bar
with long hair and earrings and Tattoos
who would
cut off an arm to wear a Hell's Angels
patch they're not interested in those
dudes because there's a million of those
guys what's your value what do you bring
to the table
can you make money can you earn can you
enforce can you intimidate you know like
like what level of violence are you
comfortable with all those things that
come into play that ended up like in the
Hell's Angels example of trying to make
myself valuable to him was the focus on
the Hell's Angels at that time was that
because of the big shootout with the
Mongols is that sort of like what is
that what's kind of sparked that that
major interest or was there has there
always been there was two main events
that really inspired that case like
really getting Steam uh the Hells Angels
Mongols riot at the Harrah's Casino in
Laughlin
um and uh the Hells Angels in Mesa had
murdered uh a woman an innocent woman
they they was in their clubhouse right
yeah they basically recruited her off
the street to come to a party the party
got out of hand uh she mouthed off in
the wrong place at the wrong time man
you don't talk [__] on these dudes in
their Clubhouse and you don't insult you
don't insult them
um she took a beating in the Mesa
Clubhouse they beat her down
um and then they stuffed her in the
trunk of a car and drove her from Mesa
out to Apache Junction Arizona which is
further east and cut her head off
um so that body was recovered and that
that there was a tie to the Hell's
Angels then with the riot then it was
like look
like we got to do something the riot was
super inspiring because it took place in
a public venue
so like gang on gang violence and and
when they keep it within their world
like how much can you contain that or
control that these guys are gonna fight
man they're gonna get it on right but
when it spills into the public when it
spills into a venue where there's Common
Man citizen there
it's it's hard to ignore and so for you
I mean and you got to know very well a
lot of the people involved in both of
those
situations and I guess you know when we
go back into building credibility and
and you and your team you know you guys
you guys uh you you know kind of join
the ranks of this this Nomad biker gang
and then when you finally make this
approach to the angels you know and you
talk about building this credibility and
building this I mean you you guys have
this whole
you know you guys were your own
motorcycle club like how how do you go
about building that what are the tools
that you need to do that yeah well like
I said like we couldn't just show up and
be like uh the Common Man Average Joe
coming off the street like you don't
knock on these dudes front door and ask
for an application right it doesn't work
that way right right so my coverage I
used the cover story I'd always used
um I was a gun Runner I could make that
make sense to them how do you make that
make sense to him I uh I obtain uh guns
in Arizona cross them into the Border in
Mexico where they're worth 10 times as
much where the cartels will pay 10 times
as much for that gun it's reverse drug
trafficking right it's it's it's is that
solution today absolutely absolutely
makes sense to them like yeah that you
know
uh that was easy
um I used my debt collector roll like
I've always got money I've always got
jobs I've always got work I've got money
in my pocket I'm not a guy that you're
gonna have to float yep
um and then that like the the the
culmination of that like the violence
aspect to it like I started getting
solicited to do murders right
um because like I never sold myself as a
hit man I never told one of those dudes
like hey man I kill yeah I'm a contract
killer I kill people for money they
assume based on my Persona how I carried
myself my cover story and then the
experience they had with me like this
guy I'll kill someone yeah you know get
approached for it like hey I'm gonna
take this dude out well you know and and
you also you have to do a lot of work
with criminal informants and and and and
I just I'm just wondering a big part of
what you do I guess what I'm trying to
get at a big part of what you do I
imagine is you got to get close to
people and you got to form like real
honest genuine relationships with them
and I you know this guy Pops I know you
guys got like enormously close news and
I'm just I'm just wondering
you know you probably had to get close
really close with people who repulsed
you and who you were disgusted by
and I imagine you also got close with
people that you genuinely liked and
cared for and you genuinely saw like a
level of decency in it whether they're a
criminal or not I'm wondering if you can
give me sort of like an example of both
of those yeah you're um so so you're
presenting this false Persona of who you
are to people and and right off the bat
you're lying to them
um but you can never Undercover
out of the human factor
um so you're you're actually you have
people targeted and and for various
reasons but
they're ultimately they're still human
beings and so like in the Hell's Angels
case for example every second of every
day wasn't spent in some kind of
criminal activity with these guys
so they would be you know running their
scheme or doing whatever they're doing
and you see that and you become a
witness to that but you're also spending
down time with them social time sure in
their homes in their living rooms
holding their babies that's it eating
with them yeah sleeping at their house
have their sleeping at your house
shooting pool with them drinking beer
with them like just and you see like
these redeeming qualities in their
personalities and give me an example
um just guys that like you run around
with and you're like man like I like
this guy and you know what if someone
came in here and uh busted a bottle on
the back of my head this dude would be
throwing down for me that's right right
like like don't you build those real
relationships
um
the problem is is God does not build us
to inherently plan on betraying someone
and in undercover work you know from the
very beginning like I'm going to try to
make a good first impression I'm going
to try to gain your trust I'm going to
gain your loyalty ultimately in some
cases I'm going to gain your love and no
one in the back of your head and as I'm
building this man I am gonna it's gonna
be a bad day for you man ultimately
because I am going to betray you yeah
and and I find that so interesting you
you talked about how you were sort of
like this pit bull dog and your your
sort of superior who is kind of running
the show how to kind of hold you back a
little bit and I'm wondering it's like
how do you how did you manage to have I
mean you have so many things going at
once right like you have this burning
desire to take these guys down but at
the same time you're also getting in
some cases extraordinarily close with
them and finding things that you bond
with things that you respect about them
sometimes you love some of these guys
but at the same time you're also trying
to maintain your own real love for for
for for your family and preserving them
the job in the oath that you took and
and I can only imagine I mean I'm
obviously that that sounds [__]
insanely stressful whatever but I mean
sure I'm just wondering like how do you
how do you maintain the real you do you
maintain the real you is it
compartmentalization like how does that
work well we've hit on this uh topic a
couple times
uh I failed at that um that's probably
my my biggest
regret my biggest humiliation or
embarrassment is that
I I was in this undercover role for for
so long for such an extended period of
time like well before and and Beyond the
Hell's Angels case that
Jaber Davis
the gun Runner debt collector Hitman
stopped becoming
what I did for a living and it started
becoming who I was but wasn't but but
that was necessary correct
in in order to accomplish what you
accomplished well and and and that was
at least that was my my defense to
myself and to my wife yep I was like you
know what
people that treat this as a gimmick
people that treat what I do as a hobby
end up dead right I have to be all in I
100 percent because I'm going to get
killed if I'm not right I I had an
argument with my wife
one point I came home I'd been away from
the house for an extended period of time
I walk in like like Jaybird Davis walks
into my house right and she's like you
cannot be gone and come here and treat
me and our kids and talk to us like
we're Street people and I was like I'm
not a light switch I can't turn this on
and off
and she's like well when you come to
this house you better install a dimmer
and dial that attitude down or don't
come back straight up and and that was
like I was super pissed off about that I
was like don't you know I'm saving the
world don't you know I'm doing all these
amazing things and like and you're going
to give me [__] for it she was exactly
right she was 100 Justified but you know
it's it's such a I I guess uh
because I know how committed you are to
your family I I see your relationship
and I just in two seconds and I I uh and
what you said about like chasing that
eight ball and making up for last night
it's such a it's such a I think a
meditation on fatherhood to begin with
because I just know through your book
you know you talked about all these kids
that you would sort of come upon in the
field you'd go into these houses where
people are doing meth and they're
they're [__] right in front of their
kids they're selling drugs in front of
their kids there's violence right in
front of these kids and you're seeing
these these young girls that are being
tossed around you're thinking of your
own daughter and like you know I I
really believe look man for me
in this world first and foremost I'm a
dad I'm a father and I'm a husband that
is my primary that is that is my my
North Star right and there's times where
I have to say you know and
but the bottom line is and I think this
is true for guys who are locked up I
think this is true for guys who are
overseas I think it's true for guys who
for whatever reason they walked away
they walked away I feel like that love
that that that bond is always there and
you always have a relationship with it
and and your North Star is how healthy
that relationship is and there's always
a way and I guess it it seems to me like
it was always present your son gave you
that rock you kept that rock with you
you know like what like I brought I
brought it you tell that story that's
who you are I mean it's a clear and I
guess like what lessons on fatherhood
did this whole chapter in your life
teach you it's it's it's gonna sound my
answers are gonna sound like
like kind of pathetic almost or like
like I'm seeking Compassion or sympathy
and I'm not because all the decisions I
made I made [__] no one made them for
me I own all of them yep but it keeps
coming back to this element of uh
failure or perceived failure like you
talked about like above all you're
grounded in your wife and your kids
right
like I lost that man they weren't the
most important thing to me
um like I think inherently like I'm
selfish that's a very unflattering thing
to say about yourself
I made decisions for me about me what
was good for me what I wanted to do and
I didn't think about my wife and I
didn't think about my kids you're like
along for the right and I and I settled
that in my head because I was giving
them I was providing them a comfortable
life they had a nice house they had food
they had clothes they went to good
schools you know my wife had had a good
car to drive they didn't have to worry
about money like I balanced that by
saying like you're like I'm giving you a
comfortable life but I wasn't giving
them presents sure I wasn't giving them
I I wasn't there right I was like I was
buying
my family I was I was paying for my
family by giving them things and I
thought like like somehow that was like
love or that was a real relationship
and that I mean that's you know like
we're like we're talking to an audience
like I don't like I don't know the
people out there that's a pretty
humiliating thing to say about yourself
but like we said earlier if I don't if I
if I'm not if I don't come clean yeah
like I'm counterfeit then yeah yeah yeah
I mean and also can't do nothing about
nothing until you admit that it's there
I mean you you'll never address a
problem unless you look at it right well
you're like literally when you're like I
was constantly pushing the envelope and
I did everything as hard and as fast and
as long as I could and then when the
operation was done like then the fun
time came and I partied as hard and as
fast and as long as I could and I like I
pushed
I pushed the envelope every day on
everything and and my relationships and
so you know like I retired eight years
ago and like the saying like uh it's
better to burn out than fade away I did
both I burned out and faded away I spent
so much time on my couch now I've been
reupholstered twice
what is your relationship with the kids
like now it's it's really good I bet um
and my relationship with Gwen is really
good I can see that
um but I'll tell you what of no credit
to me I did every single thing I could
direct that
um there was countless times where I
should have came home and all my clothes
should have been in the front yard and
the lock should have been changed I made
a million mistakes with Gwen and my kids
and I'm blessed that they've given me a
million and one second chances to fix it
beautiful
um and so I'm trying to take that one
chance yep and trying to like see if I
can finally like on the back half of my
life maybe get it right because I spent
the first half of my life getting
everything wrong and when you when you
say that you know you were like pushing
the envelope in all areas again
do you feel like that was necessary and
in order to you know especially when you
were is that the rock it is wow
wow
can you tell the story of that rock so
during the course like so my kids never
knew me as anything other than an
undercover agent they were born into it
like Gwen had a chance man she knew what
I was doing before we got married so
like like she had the opportunity to say
no the kids never had an opportunity to
say no right so
like well before the Hell's Angels case
through the Hell's Angels case
I'd be gone for extended period of time
you know smoking and Joe can come home
um and I did the bare minimum I had to
to keep my family functioning I'd mow
the grass pay the bills Pat the kids on
the head have a cup of coffee with Gwen
couldn't wait to get back out because I
loved being in gangster land what did
you ever thrived I just loved
um like the risk of it the challenge of
it how Dynamic it was how dangerous it
was
um that like pushing the envelope right
all the time
so every time I'd come home and then get
ready to leave my son who was little at
time like 8 10. run out in the yard and
say Dad don't leave yet like I got
something for you and he'd come and he'd
bring me a rock out of the yard
and
hundreds of times I had these rocks I I
kept I kept Jackie's rocks I kept one in
my pocket at all times I had them in the
saddlebags my motorcycle my undercover
car my undercover house these good luck
charms right this kid was giving me
these good luck charms I started handing
them out to my partners on the task
force I was like I don't know like what
kind of blessing or Charm this kid has
put trust me but like the violence is
swirling around us eight or ten murders
took place during that case like all
around us friends of mine people that I
was working on I was like like please
hang on to this rock right
so the last big operation we're getting
ready to kind of wrap the case up and
we're gonna go fake this murder right
and I'm
getting ready to leave
and I tell Jackie like I'll I'm almost
done and
don't leave yet Dad don't leave yet and
he brings me this rock right and he and
he and it's this rock it's the the one
he the the one that I keep with me and
he says I've been saving this one for
you it's special it's shaped like a
heart
and so like I'm a 40 year old dad and
I'm trying to comfort like this 10 year
old boy and I said all the things that I
have been neglecting with you I'm gonna
fix I'm gonna get done with this and I'm
gonna come home and we're gonna play
catch and we're gonna ride bikes and
we're gonna wrestle we're going to swim
and go to the movies
right and I said it's all because of
your rocks dude these good luck charms
and I'm like they work so good I've been
giving them to all my partners
and this little boy standing on my
driveway and Tears start running down
his cheeks he's standing there no shirt
no shoes and he's like
those were not good luck charms and you
shouldn't have given them to anybody
they were just for you they were only
for you Dad
and so like I'm like trying to figure
out like for years I thought he'd been
giving me good luck charms and he's like
that's for you to put in your pocket and
every time you think someone's gonna
hurt you you could put your hand in
there and touch it and that would be
like me being there to help you fight
him wow
and that was like that was the worst day
and the best day of my life the worst
day is that a 10 year old boy had to
teach his 40 year old father what my job
was the best day was that my
ten-year-old son taught me what my job
was
um
and so man I put a huge amount of battle
damage on my phone that's what I did to
my kids yeah all because what because I
wanted to be Donnie Brasco part two
um
for what and then you leave no one cares
no one remembers you no one remembers
the cases you know you like you you you
retire and the next day like the people
on your task force are arguing over the
stapler on your desk who gets it that's
that's how important you are right right
and then
you know ultimately this this this this
case is like brought against these guys
there's got to be some feeling of like
deep satisfaction there's gotta like
what what is that what
so uh so I I go through this dispute
with my agency after the after the case
right and I felt like
uh the threats that we had faced that me
and my family faced that weren't
addressed I felt super betrayed by that
sure right
um and I was upset by it and then like
the light bulb went off one day and my
head cleared and I'm like dude like that
was your karma man you had it coming you
betrayed your family you betrayed your
wife and your kids for this job think
about all the people over 27 years that
you had investigated that you won their
love and you betrayed them
like how you how does that feel man how
you like that and you know when it
happened to me I didn't like it very
much and and and so once again you
looked at this like again what many
would look at is this like massive
achievement or whatever but you looked
in your life you looked at the parts
that didn't work you looked at the parts
that were failure how can I correct this
first of all these people that you won
the love of and and you betrayed them
the the the these these criminals that
you ended up bringing down or whatever
that is can you talk about somebody
specific that you felt really bad about
that that that that that that that you
came to love that that ultimately you
brought down you know like like I can
kind of squeeze that into one story
right so we let go we spend two years
with these guys and and make hundreds of
them
right and indicted 55 people 16 of mon
Rico we indicted the guys that had
beheaded Cynthia Garcia
um
so I'm briefing the SWAT team I'm
briefing The Raid team for the for the
takedown
and in the process I'm talking about the
different characters that they're going
to be hunting and where they're going to
be and how violent they are yeah of
course and so in it I'm like hey when
you hit
JoJo right right like man like the
dude's a pretty decent dude right like
like
like look I know you got to take him
down yeah but like like like this dude
easy right yep now Jimmy when you hit
his house beat his [__] balls off
right because he's a [__] [__]
yeah and what and can you
can you describe that line like what is
it why
what made him an [__] what made you
love you well
probably no different than probably some
of them felt about me but it's like you
you put a group of people together and
there's some people you click with
there's other people you don't so
um the people that I disliked probably
had I'm sure had people that absolutely
adored them the people that I liked
probably had Arch enemies sure um it was
just like the chemistry that I had with
certain people whether it be good or bad
was my chemistry I guess the reason why
I ask is you know there's there's a lot
of folks that I've become really close
with and some folks that we've had on
the show who who spent a lot of time in
law enforcement not in the capacity that
that you have for these prolonged
undercover these these huge operations
that you've been on but one thing that I
hear over and over again from from from
from folks in law enforcement especially
when we start to talk about you know
this kind of anti-police movement that's
kind of taking over the country recently
and and and and all of the videos that
we're seeing about police brutality and
how it's like changing the course of
policing and one thing that I hear from
from a lot of great cops and guys I
really respect is you can't make it
personal like it's business you can't
make it personal when you start making
it personal that's not bad [__] but I
think like in your case what's so
[__] astounding to me is like making
it personal is kind of everything for
you right like you've gotta like making
it personal is also like your armor like
you're not get these [__] no
one's getting close to Hell's Angels
clubhouses you're going to New York City
you're making a few phone calls you're
in there [__] an ATF agent you're in
there like I talked to melchancy today
as we were talking today is one of the
most feared Hells Angels in history Mr
187 and he was just like what you were
able to do was like [__] unprecedent
and he said by the way he's like he they
would have never been able to do it to
us he was like he's like you're able to
talk to talk walk the walk you always
had money on you you would say you're
gonna do something you're gonna do it
when violence came up you threw hands
you were like down to like you and and
he said that like look man like they you
said you guys [__] killed a Mongol
and you showed pictures of it like
you know what Mel said is I guess in the
Hell's Angels in order to even think
about getting patched in it's got to be
you got to know somebody for five years
you know yeah they said what you did was
unprecedented and I imagine it's because
you were able to form these personal
relationships and I guess what I'm so
you know you had to make this personal
correct yeah I I absolutely it's it's
got to be personal it's got to be
important to you
um
but on the other side of that like so
operationally it's very personal right
but then at some point
the these people that you've grown to to
at least like
right are sitting on the sidewalk in
front of their house with their hands
cuffed behind their back right you have
created
I've created the very worst day ever in
that person's life and I'm responsible
for it and there I am standing in front
of them
um then the personal side comes off I
never mocked anybody over the course of
my career I never said like I got you
see how's that feel I tricked you you
fell for it you bought it not one time
what is the main emotion I was the dude
who was like dude man you know what
today is a freaking terrible day for you
man but like it can be a great day like
you like maybe this is what you needed
Mel Chansey right no better example
maybe this is what you needed to get
right like man like so they're sitting
there and they're pissed off and they
hate me right they want to just rip my
throat out like dude can I get you a
cigarette man putting a cigarette in
their mouth and and moving it in them
out of their mouth so they can take a
drag do you need some water let me get
you a bottle of water
those small little elements of humanity
and compassion like I've had people that
I've that I've arrested that said you
know what man I didn't like you but you
always treated me good that's right you
always treated me like and I think
that's the key for any of us men treat
people the way you want to be treated in
anything right right and I feel like
that's like these great you you you know
these these great cops that I've I've
gotten to know and love over the years
it's like they all have what you're
talking about it's like empathy man it's
like hey man therefore the grace of God
go on man like I could be in that
situation and there is this fine line
and there's at the end of the day man
we're all playing the cards that were
dealt there was less just sort of forces
separating us say you're on this side
you're on this side I mean the way that
you were able to ultimately get these
guys off the street at a time in their
life where they were causing horrible
horrible [__] things the way you were
doing it was to be able to say hey man I
open my heart up to you well you know
we're both friends with Mel chances like
I cannot think of a better example I
mean that dude was the most dangerous
cat on the Planet meant and legit and
feared like by everyone and and he
earned that like like that wasn't just
because he was bigger than everybody or
like like he Mel earned his reputation
yeah
um
and then he has a downturn he gets
caught up in it right and he realized
uh like probably through that downturn
that God had a bigger plan from him
absolutely and that he could not fulfill
that plan
living in a steel cage and eating
bologna sandwiches and lime Jello for
the rest of his life he had to escape
that and now look at like what he's
doing with his life and how he's
changing the world and how he's
inspiring people towards God it's
incredible like how do you not love that
how do you not he and like he talks
about you he like loves you you know he
loves the guy he loves Bayless you know
like he lo you know and and and and I
guess with that you know like what does
it say about criminality in general you
know something else in your book that
that really hit me man was uh you know
you you know I think it was about that
pops but it was about like sea eyes in
general criminal informants and that you
said that you know you're really going
to folks and you're offering them a
chance to do something different like to
to to to to have a different kind of
purpose and then a lot of these guys
either haven't had that opportunity or
they're they're they're caught up in the
what can you say sort about criminal
informants in general and then what can
you say sort of about criminality and
folks
playing the cards that they're looked I
think we both know there's some folks
that are just deranged and there's some
folks that are just kind of led by a
little bit of evil whatever that is but
what can you say about sort of the
common criminal and is there
is there another path is there another
path in just sort of like targeting them
taking them out and incarcerating them
like what do you think about that well I
think that uh a lot of times
they end up in the situations they are
because
they're so desperate they can't even
hope for Hope anymore like hope has
escaped them hope isn't anything that
factors in anymore
um and when you're hopeless
what do you care you're going to do
whatever it is you do you know like now
a lot of them are looking for a sense of
belonging to something there's something
missing in their life and that in that
social aspect of life
um like just like taking it down to
street gangs like a lot of these uh
these gang members don't have fathers at
home that gang is their father that gang
provides them that that grounding that a
dad does
um there's Hell's Angels that like for
different reasons they wanted to belong
to a family and now if you if you love
that world
and the family that is inviting you in
is a family that carries with it
intimidation
and power and respect
and now by putting that patch on your
back like like Joe nobody all of a
sudden you walk in a bar and people are
moving out of your way people want to
buy you drinks people want to give you
drugs girls want to hang on you
when without that patch you're invisible
man that's that sounds pretty powerful
yes sir like it's it's it's not it
doesn't matter if I agree with it or not
I understand it sure like like who like
who doesn't want that sure sure right
and that's the that's the view yeah
dude like straight up rock stars in
their world yep like the way they're
treated and the way they're admired
um
no doubt yep yep and and you know you
alluded to it a little bit before but I
just you know I I want to just talk
briefly about like kind of the Betrayal
that you felt from the from the agency
in general and like kind of walk us
through that your home was burned down
correct and and um you know the Hell's
Angels and then through MS-13 and
Aryan Brotherhood like you had green
lights on you and and hits I mean what
the [__] is that like man I mean what it
like uh the worst part of of that entire
event was that I had brought that world
uh down on my family I can't imagine
um and and the the the code was broken
and it like like it wasn't just about me
anymore it was like hurting me there was
there was uh comments made to me like
dude like we know how to hurt you and it
ain't putting a hole in you it ain't
shooting you dude it's freaking hurting
your family like like any of us like any
like so how are those messages delivered
to you oh so many different ways like
like I had first hand face-to-face
conversations
um the the infiltration case ends and
then my true uh identity like who they
thought to be jber Davis turns out to be
Jay Dobbins instead of the the gun
Runner debt collector turns out to be an
ATF agent
um so that the Angels issued contracts
on me they were farmed out to the Aryan
Brotherhood they were farmed out to the
MS-13 18th Street picked one up here in
Los Angeles
um other uh side people came in in like
like lone wolves who wanted to make
their bones
um
there was a letter intercepted out of
the prison by the guy that beheaded
Cynthia Garcia that I helped locked up
that said like why are you guys trying
to like like shoot or stab this dude
stick them with a AIDs contaminated
needle man he's gonna go down and like
we won't be held accountable for it
same letter said you want to make this
dude pay you really want to hurt him
kidnap his wife and videotape her being
gang raped and show it to him you want
to hurt him that's how you hurt him
threats to kidnap my kids off the bus so
Jay how does that like what does that do
to you man well the the first emotion
when you when you see something like
that uh
it's it's uh it's it's pretty dangerous
right because like I think all of us
know like like how to solve that yep
um
and my frustration was when those
threats started coming out that um I
like I never one time said
well the threats were proven to be
credible and valid and reliable threats
they were accurate threats
but like my agency didn't want to
investigate them they were just there
was too many they were too massive they
came to me and said dude you're on your
own where would you like us to start
would you like us to start with the
Hell's Angels with the contracts you
want to score the MS-13 how about if we
start working on the ABS maybe we'll go
talk to 18th Street what about this
where do you want us to start like dude
you're on your own it's too big we can't
handle it even though you're you're at
this point one of the most distinguished
ATF agents of all time what do you mean
you're on your own like I I don't
that's that was that's how blunt it was
put to me like you're on your own to
solve this so I'm sitting there I'm like
okay like I don't really have any
resources I don't have the ability to go
hide there's no witness security for law
enforcement but I mean and how are you
how are you living your day-to-day
you know when you hear like are you are
you constantly looking over your
shoulder I mean what what what's the
mindset looking over my shoulder
paranoid like wanting help begging for
help expecting help feeling like I'd
earned or deserved help and not having
it come what does this do with you and
your wife like where where are you guys
at you're not aware of the threats yeah
and and um like like why like why she
stuck it out I've I don't know because
it would have been really easy for her
to cut and run
really easy for it too and you know like
like
so the agency doesn't that doesn't react
and like so I get in a dispute with them
like hey man you need to give me some
help here right
um
so they doubled down on me and they
unmask all my cover documents they they
took all like all like my address had
been hidden my my driver's registration
all those things had been they made that
all open source information that was now
public record three months after that my
house gets burned down and then no one
comes to investigate the arson
and then I find out behind uh behind
closed doors dude you are the target of
the arson I'm like what wait what
they're like dude they've rented office
space they've tasked they've manned a
task force and they're recording your
calls they're going to try to pin this
arson on you so like when I talk about
like we talked about earlier about the
feelings of betrayal and like how I
spent my life betraying people and how I
felt like during the way I did my job I
betrayed my family
like I like I almost felt like like I
had it coming I felt like dude you
created this Karma like how do you like
it again that same thing you're looking
at something you did you're looking at
your own failure you you're you're
framing this because the only thing that
you can change is sort of like making it
your but this is you know and so the
thing is though it's it sounds like I
have this like like this bitterness
about it I don't I love ATF I love the
agents out there with their boots on the
ground who are doing it the right way I
ran in to a perfect storm of power
corruption and arrogance and
incompetence in a little window that all
took care of each other that all
protected each other and the trippy
thing is the same people that were that
were doing this to me at the exact same
time are the people that were running
atf's operation Fast and Furious and
running thousands of assault weapons to
the cartels wow which would have never
been discovered had Brian Terry the
border patrol agent not been murdered
with one of the guns that ATF sent to
the cartels that doesn't happen
operation Fast and Furious never gets
known about wow right same cats doing it
at the same time they were um
that they had insulated themselves and I
guess it's the the saying uh can you
just explain Fast and Furious for to
people that don't don't know about it
yeah operation Fast and Furious was this
corrupt gun running investigation where
ATF which is uh
tasked with uh preventing Firearms
trafficking in some kind of skewed like
uh
Twisted plan
was allowing thousands of assault
weapons to go directly to the cartels
and they were like they were using it
for like statistical reasons they were
counting guns in Mexico and they were
like bodies were stacking up in Mexico
and they were using those dead bodies to
justify like how we need more gun
control laws here to prevent guns going
into Mexico because of all the death and
violence that was being created when
they were the ones that were created who
was funny who was profiting off of it
who
uh
I don't you know what but but because
because of fat but but because of Fast
and Furious sort of be getting outed
that that ultimately outed the guys that
were sort of [__] with you yeah but
you know what like none of them paid
none of them paid for what they did to
me none of them paid for Fast and
Furious actually some of them got
promoted wow
um but
for the people that make the rules there
are no rules they can do whatever they
want and they do and they know they
can't and they know they can get away
with it
and and do you feel I mean I was talking
to Mel about this earlier I mean do you
feel like those threats are still out
there for you I well I'll say this I
don't live my life in fear I live my
life with concern
um
if I put myself in the wrong place at
the wrong time with the wrong
combination of people I could have a
problem but do I think that they're
hunting me no right um like I don't like
I don't hide I'm not looking for a
problem right right you put yourself out
I don't hide right um I live my life
with concern
um
but like I'm you know if if I get
confronted with a problem I will walk
away if you give me the opportunity I
will run away but if you Corner me yeah
like we're all going to the hospital
right like all of us are right like I
always felt like I've got God's hand on
one shoulder and a pistol on my hip and
between all of us we'll figure it out
yep um and that's not cocky I'm not
looking for a fight I don't want to
fight first I don't want to fight these
dudes I can't beat these guys yeah I've
shown I can't beat them yeah yeah um
it's funny because you know when I don't
know it's funny but you know what what
you know what I was talking to Mel about
it you know the way he said is like you
know honestly like now looking at your
case and what you were able to do
you know because I know George Christie
a little bit too sure I know George as
well and and uh
you know I'm I'm dealing with the thing
up in in my little town where I live
um uh
woman that's real really close with us
helps helps raise my kids raise my kids
since they were little
um you know her her oldest
her oldest son when he was 14 uh got
linked up with a um a little gang out of
Santa Paul I live in a little town
called Ojai California and uh he uh you
know he's 14 years old didn't really
grow up with a dad a little bit of abuse
he got linked up with the gang only a
couple months but he got into it with a
bigger kid
um who was in sort of an offshoot kind
of uh a gang that was connected with the
angels down in Ventura and the kid was
bigger he was older they got into a
fight at the party they both went
outside they agreed to have a fight both
of them pulled out knives 14 year old
ended up killing the 16 year old but he
got sentenced to 36 to life no priors no
nothing as a minor
um
but you know the Angels really uh you
know to this woman that I'm very close
with uh
surrounded her house every night rubbing
their engine scared her intimidated or
threatened her uh and um
you know I really care about this woman
and and you know like I've tried to do
sort of what I what I can do in it to
help
um those dudes have their phds and
violence and intimidation they know how
to scare you know how to scare you you
know and and and when I talked to Mel
about you know this situation
you know the way he puts it
um and I don't know if you've heard this
before but I just found it interesting
it's like look man you got him like like
for him he's like at this point
everybody looks at what you did as like
you were just bet you won like you duped
them like they [__] up like you know
like you you beat him and and you were
yeah who you said you were you had your
[__] tight and and now there's like sort
of like an honor in that there's like
you know and like hey look man if
someone's threatening me or my family
that's not gonna necessarily make me
sleep well at night but I just I wonder
what what you thought of that when I've
encountered I've got uh relationships on
various levels with with uh current and
ex Hells Angels
um and I've had you know like pretty
dangerous guys saying like look dude I
don't like you I don't like the way you
did this but um
you're you're pretty dang good at it man
and we understand that we do what we do
and there's guys out there that do what
you do you were better than us that's
right um
like like no one gets a trophy for it no
one gets a trophy for winning that's
right right that's right
um ultimately they won right um after
two years of pain and suffering and
blood and violence and all this stuff
and then all the aftermath and all my
battle with a with ATF the Hell's Angels
are stronger today than they were when I
started on them they didn't get weaker
they got better they got smarter you
know I've had complaints with my No
Angel book people are saying dude like
okay good story good cop story right
interesting you inspired people to
become Hell's Angels with that people
like saw the other side of it the glamor
on the dark side of it like you like
that's a recruiting tool for them
and I'm like oh okay
okay it's because it's all about choices
like like for all of us right everyone's
sitting here look at yourself and say
choices you made earlier in your life
the ones you made obviously put you on a
path like you're successful and you're
famous and you're a movie star you could
have made a choice that exact same day
that had you locked up oh man I was
right there there's choices 100 and like
when you're a young kid and you don't
have life's experiences behind you and
you're confronted with those Life
Choices
man you can't get it wrong because when
you do it's unrecoverable
what are you most proud of like what are
you most proud of uh I'm proud of my
family and I'm and I'm proud of them for
them
um I'm proud of them uh they they really
truly showed me what love is because
they they just they stuck by me and like
I gave them no reason to
I gave them that there's there's
absolutely no reason why they should be
in my life and even if they were remote
uh removed from my life there's really
no reason for them to even have any
communication with me that's how much
battle damage I put on them and there
they are man wow every day there they
are that's beautiful man and and and and
right now with this you know like this
sort of like anti-cop movement in this
country like what what's your take on
that well yeah I mean you look like
we're one day removed from we're filming
one day removed from the Vivaldi
shooting in Texas we're a week removed
from Buffalo from the supermarket
shooting in Buffalo
um so there's all these arguments out
there of
uh you know like like more gun laws gun
control right
um like I I think we need to do
something different if I knew the
solution I would offer it but I know
what the answer is not I don't know what
the answer is I know what it's not
what's it the answer is not to take
money away from the police to have less
police that is not the answer we need to
give we need like the exact opposite of
defund the police over fund the police
get better get more cops get better cops
train them better every expert out there
and I'm not an expert every expert out
there says like dude train train train
them train them to de-escalate train
them like all the things the
shortcomings exactly right
um don't take money away from them don't
try to weaken them it weakens all of us
man do you have any opinion do you have
any opinion you know with with what
happened uh you know yesterday I mean do
you do you
I mean look man like your perspective on
like illegal guns I mean that's like
that's what you did man I mean like what
what do you think about that what's your
take on guns what's your take on how
easy it is to get them like you know I I
I know you said I mean like are you a
big gun guy do you still carry like what
yeah I carry but I wouldn't consider
myself a gun guy or a gun expert by any
means
um
I I I do believe this there's 350
million guns in the United States
um
if if I am a criminal or if I have a
violent mindset and I'm willing to go
out and murder someone which is the
ultimate sin the ultimate crime
do I care what the gun law says right
about my ability to get it like we both
know and like like we're in an affluent
area here right we both know in 10
minutes we could get our hands on a gun
without knowing anybody in this
neighborhood just going around and
starting to shake some hands 100 in 10
minutes we'd have a conversation if you
really wanted it 100 right and that like
that's not uh that's not like an
undercover guy talking that or that's
not a guy who's experienced in in that
world and and the techniques that's
anybody anybody anybody you know what I
bring my gun with me every time I come
to the city I live out in the country
every time I come to City I always bring
bring it with me that is so different
from like how I was when I was growing
up like I grew up in a city that was the
murder capital of the country
um you know like like Nick will tell you
you know we grew up in an environment
where like you know where we grew up it
was like pretty safe you know but you
you went a block to the left you blocked
to the right and there was there's kids
getting shot at school there's just
shootings all the time and it was and so
I was growing up you know to to really
like hate guns I I just spies them and
if you had a problem with somebody you
settled with your hands like that's what
you did I just feel like for me you know
now this kind of front row ticket that I
get in different cities to law
enforcement and getting to know these
people from the the shows I do and the
relationships that I get to make it
doesn't seem to be like that anymore
everyone's shooting each other the gun
is the great equalizer uh when you were
kids you'd Slug It Out right the best
fighter or the biggest guy or the
strongest guy wins doesn't work like
that anymore the skinniest most Punky
most wimpy most coward
can win because the gun is the great
equalizer so is the answer then so is
the answer then more guns are more
people in schools like what do you like
what do you think it's just like it's
it's such a societal question yeah you
look at like you just look at the world
like like in the and the gun the gun
argument part of it you look at like the
the issues on the border you look at the
the war in Ukraine you look at the
abortion uh issues are all uh back on
fight well not that they've never been
not on fire but now they're just
prevalent again
um uh gas prices the economy and as a
society we're freaking giving two [__]
about what's going on with Johnny Depp
and Amber hurt it's crazy like it's
crazy really crazy
so right now I mean like you're you're
you you coach you coach football you're
coaching High School football you know
you're in a position right now where
like you're shaping young men's lives
and hearts in a way I mean just some of
the people that have the biggest effect
in my life or my high school football
coaches I'm just wondering like you know
what are you seeing sort of like in the
young men that you coach what what are
you seeing in that High School
environment what are you seeing that
encourages you what are you seeing that
like disappoints you
um how does what happened yesterday in
Texas how does it
you know how does it play upon sort of
like your role as a coach and Mentor for
these young men well um my kids are out
of school but like I know that that you
have still have younger kids like how
terrorizing to have kids going to school
now and not knowing if like when you
send them off or when you put them on
the school bus whether you get to see
them at the end of the day and like it's
not like some kind of dream sequence uh
uh
illusion or imagination it's real it's
happening all the time I think there's I
think I read a stat where there's been
30 school shootings this year we're at
the end of May
when we're at a point where
you have as good a chance of getting
shot
going to school as you do doing a drug
deal yeah
tell you what there wasn't there wasn't
19 uh or 26 drug murders yesterday I
mean maybe there was maybe but between
uh Second and and fifth or sixth grade
that's insane
it's insane it's you know what to be
honest with you I mean I spent like my
entire professional life trying to make
an impact on that
um and it it's like the in the the
entirety of it
has caused me to question everything I
ever stood for and everything I ever
believed in
um
and it's it's it's
I don't want to give up but like there's
days when I just want off the
merry-round
I just went off the Merry-Go-Round like
I I did nothing I accomplished nothing I
changed nothing
um and
like like I just
I don't know I think that
um you know I imagine like you know it's
all about what can we do today and like
who can we influence a day and what can
we you know uh
I don't know I I mean it is I mean
there's there's no like easy way to you
know talk about kind of you know what
happened yesterday and and uh I can't
imagine what these what these folks are
going through and I just uh I don't
think if if you haven't
if you haven't lost a kid or lost a kid
in those circumstances
all you can do is is empathize with it
and show compassion for it because you
can't say like oh man I know how that
feels no actually you know what you
don't if you haven't gone through it you
have no idea where I have no idea what
that feels like no idea yeah all I can
do is try to be compassionate for it
empathetic towards it I have no idea
what that feels like yeah yeah and not
pretend like we got the answers you know
no yeah yeah I was uh at Columbine High
School about six hours after the that
was the first not the first school
shooting but the first big one yeah
right
and I can honestly say my DNA was
altered that day like walking around
that crime scene
um I went from being a pretty happy
joyful person to be in a really angry
like I just I I wanted to just go like
rage and fight and like lock people up
and like take guns off the street and
and stand in between like the good and
innocent people in the communities and
the Predators who wanted to ruin that
for him I I like it really set that home
I really like began to take a lot of
pride in the responsibility in that
um but like my my DNA changed that day
and it wasn't like there's there's dead
bodies of these kids in the school in
the cafeteria in the library and there's
and I mean it was a mess and I'll tell
you what what burned on me and I and I
still can't get that Vision out of my
head
there were backpacks there were book
bags scattered all over that campus so
like and you'd think that like you'd be
focused on the the body of a kid you
know or the or the the blood stains and
and the Carnage there
like I don't like my brain somehow has
kind of erased that but I can't get rid
of all those book bags all those
backpacks scattered everywhere kids were
shucking their their belongings and like
kids who went to school that day to like
enjoy their friends go to class go to
their after school activities go to
sports
ended up like running for their lives
and dying there that day and I was like
so so angry with that
like I was gonna like I'm gonna do
something about this or die trying yep
yep
um
man I uh this was like truly awesome bro
like I I I admire you so much man and
and I think beyond all else I mean not
even all these incredible the the life
that you're living in the life that you
lead but uh you're just like super
humble man and and honest and direct and
I I uh I know I'm a better guy for
knowing you man it's serious I I really
really appreciate you you doing it and
um I got just undying uh Limitless
respect for you bro I I think for all of
us for like what you do for all of us
here on your crew for me like
like like just try to change the world
for the better yeah like I said like
like maybe it's just one person yeah
maybe it's one moment in one person's
day that's right that's right all those
events have made me more spiritual I
lost everything I lost
my reputation like any any thought I had
of leaving a legacy
um I was bankrupted by my by my fight
against the government I had destroyed
my family relationships I'd lost friends
had turned their back on me I lost
everything
and then I realized after everything's
gone
like God was still there
like like he was still there man
like in spite of all my mistakes and all
the things I screwed up he was still
there and I learned I I learned one
really important thing if the only time
you're talking to God is when you're in
trouble you're in trouble you're in
trouble that's
right you know
um so so the great thing the best thing
and why I wouldn't change anything is
because it all of that brought me closer
to God God doesn't come in and rescue
you
from all your suffering he uses that
suffering to pull you closer to him like
you have to go through that and he's
like saying like like are you gonna come
to me are you gonna turn to me are you
going to have faith are you going to
believe are you going to keep trying to
do things your way Jay because check it
out dude they don't work out good on
your plan follow my plan I had to learn
that the hard way
um
you know information
is not does not necessarily equal
knowledge knowledge does not necessarily
equal wisdom and for me
like wisdom was always something that
came to me right after I needed it
thank you right on man thank you for
having me thank you guys too
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was something about building bridges and
and bringing people together and
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I going to have my
son Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones